I remember in the early days thinking
obviously the ability to send value
instantly anywhere on earth is gonna be
a big thing but everyone was saying it's
just a joke it's not gonna work and to
have big financial conferences about
this technology five or six years after
I got involved is certainly exciting
the blockchain industries flagship
annual conference which was held this
week in New York City had 1500 attendees
and a hundred and 50 speakers who came
from all over the world eight years
after this technology was first
described in a nine ph paper dropped on
the internet by a mysterious computer
scientist interest is suddenly exploding
among blue chip financial firms who are
exploring how bitcoin and blockchain can
make their operations more efficient the
governor of Delaware pitched a new
initiative intended to draw companies in
this space to relocate to his state
former Treasury Secretary Larry Summers
touted the blockchains disruptive
potential and Microsoft the one
slumbering tech giant was out in force
embracing blockchain technology with the
hope of finally getting a jump on its
competitors I actually think the
government currencies are gonna go away
that my children and grandchildren will
laugh at the flag money we used to use
the mainstream interest on display was a
little surreal for Erik Voorhees a
libertarian who got involved with
Bitcoin in 2011 launched the gambling
platform Satoshi dice the following year
and now had shape-shift a crypto
currency exchange if you look at the
Bitcoin blockchain industry today our
most of the libertarians I don't know it
mostly it's just business people but
that's fine business people will grow
the system and to me it doesn't matter
because the freedom that the asset
brings to people happens on the back of
the technology so as long as the
technology is growing that would be good
for humans
but the buzzword at this year's
conference was blockchain not Bitcoin a
distinction that's indicative of
mainstream misgivings about working with
a system that's open for anyone to use
many banks are partnering with companies
building so-called private blockchains
to mimic some aspects of bitcoins
architecture except they're designed to
be closed off and accessible only to
chosen parties the big companies want to
improve themselves they do not want to
disrupt themselves William muga yarr is
an investor and the author of a new
business guide to the blockchain
industry that draws analogies to the
early days of the internet when open
access drove rapid innovation big
companies like to talk about using the
blog chain without Bitcoin and using
maybe 10% of the capabilities of what
Bitcoin has given us and I think it is a
mistake but Voorhees is confident that
open and permissionless block chains
will ultimately prevail even in the
banking sector simply because they're
more efficient I have no problem with
financial industry inviting the Trojan
horse of blockchain technology into
their walled gardens because I know how
powerful the technology is a Monday
morning just as the conference was
getting underway in New York the
industry was abuzz Craig Wright a 45
year old Australian computer scientist
had just publicly declared that he is
Satoshi Nakamoto the man who created
Bitcoin under that pseudonym eight years
ago some people will believe some people
weren't and to tell you the truth I
don't really care the claim was given
credence by Gavin Andresen the chief
scientist at the Bitcoin foundation who
flew to London last month to meet write
and vet his story I'm 98% sure
Craig Wright is Satoshi meanwhile other
prominent figures in the community
disputed the evidence and labeled Wright
a likely imposter including Vitalik
Butera in the creator of the popular
blockchain platform aetherium by day two
of the conference Wright wrote on his
blog that he would provide extraordinary
proof to support his claim and then two
days later he took it back saying that
he didn't have the courage so why does
this question bring up such strong
feelings within the industry if he
aauggh a hero who's kind of mythical
than you know everyone can kind of
project whatever they want on to him
whereas if it turns into a like a real
living breathing figure then all of a
sudden it's it's a person and you can go
and criticize this tax history in a sex
life and it's a really different story
satoshis mysterious identity helped
Bitcoin attract such an ideologically
diverse following by allowing its
devotees to attach their own meanings to
this hard-to-define
technology but most people agree that
today it's taken on a life of its own
everyone understands that it is detached
from any single person the incentives
built in the system are really beautiful
and so a lots of people have an
incentive to make it work
it's gratifying to see events like this
it shows if you have a great technology
and you make an open and available to
the world the world will eventually
notice it might take a few years but
people will notice
you